on n'est pas sûr qu'un assistant
personnel on est sur bien plus que ça on
est sur un objet qui apporte une
dimension à l'assistant personnel au
côté intelligence artificielle avec un
google assistons avec un amazon alexa et
c'est vachement cool et moi je vous dis
ce que j'aime et ce que je trouve
vraiment très très très intéressant là
dessus c'est
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler intelligence
aujourd'hui pas par l'intelligence
artificielle
je suppose que vous connaissez ça elle
google remis à c'est une enceinte
connectée de google intelligente avec
google assistant il ya le petit modèle
et ya le grand modèle c'est google comme
ça c'est bien ça permet de faire plein
de choses vous lui posez les questions
qu'est google n'a fait si elle fait ça
il allume les lumières elle vous donne
la météo elle vous dit plein de 60
autres quotidiens
c'est un vrai assistant souvent dire il
manque que la parole sauf que là elle
n'a que la parole donc ça c'est cool ou
mais une solution beaucoup plus loin
c'est une solution de la marque
française qui s'appelle archos je vous
présente
archos lots 7 cette vidéo est sponsorisé
par archos archos m'a demandé de tester
sa nouvelle enceinte tablettes
connectées intelligente
archos et le set alors je vous lis tout
de suite c'est pas parce que archos m'a
demandé de la tester m'a demandé de
regarder de vous dire ce que j'en
pensais il que ça veut dire que je vais
pas être objectif
bien au contraire d'ailleurs archos
troubles et dans votre slip
parce que il se peut que le tronc des
points négatifs
non mais franchement au-delà de ça je
reste vraiment objectif quand je fais ce
genre de test même s'il marque me paye
pour le faire
soyez tranquilles soyez rassurés là
dessus par contre je trouve ça vraiment
un truc qui est cool avec 705 connectés
mais avec sept objets connectés
intelligents vous allez alliés l'audio
vous avez actuellement avec un écran
alors ce n'est pas une tablette haut de
gamme
on n'est pas sur des galaxy tab lesca
qu'on n'est pas sur des produits comme
ça on va pas du tout alors les mêmes
performances n'ont pas du tout recherché
à me choque donc si vous voulez acheter
une tablette pour pas cher franchement
il faut pas aller là dessus c'est pas du
tout du tout du tout l'adn de ce produit
l'adn de ce produit c'est vous poser sur
une table vous poser quelques pas à la
position verticale ou à la position
horizontale et vous allez avoir des
images en plus pour vous aider parce que
c'est un assistant personnel
mais ce n'est pas une tablette ça c'est
vraiment important de faire la
distinction parce que si vous l'achetez
en tant que tablette vous risquez très
rapidement d'être déçu parce que voilà
c'est pas du tout la fonction première
les performances sont pas complètement
officie en arrière mais par contre elle
fait vraiment le job pour ce qu'on lui
demande donc que je vous propose c'est
qu'on la regarde de plus près on regarde
quels sont les points positifs les
points négatifs ce qu'on peut faire avec
comment ça marche quel est l'intérêt
qu'elle est là bien
cette bécane mais au final vous me direz
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire vous avez deux possibilités
soit vous la mettiez comme ça la
verticale soit vous la positionner comme
ça à l'horizontale normalement vous
n'avez pas le petit câble qui vous
embête juste que moi je suis un petit
peu court en terme de file donc gelé
directement ici tu voulu mettre à la
verticale ça sera probablement plus
alors ce qui est cool c'est que là vous
voyez vous avez un écran de 7 pouces
c'est du lcd c'est une dalle épaisse la
luminosité
je vais la poussée à fond comme ça vous
voyez c'est de l'android bien tout
simplement on est sur android 8.1 oreo
le tactile est ok ça fonctionne bien
c'est une dalle ipc du lcd la révolution
c'est du 1280 x 800 pixels
on est sur du hd l'idée là dessus c'est
pas du tout d'avoir du full hd parce
qu'on cherche pas à avoir quelque chose
de complètement dingue en termes de
performances l'idée c'est vraiment un
assistant donc on a un écran on cherche
pas le truc le plus ou fille sim
moi je trouve que plus efficaces en
termes de performance c'est pas une
machine qui est complètement dingue on
est sur un médiathèque
c'est un 8167 on a deux gigas de ram on
a 16 giga de stockage que vous pouvez
augmenter grâce à une carte micro sd
vous allez pouvoir faire brancher
directement ici si vous le souhaitez ce
qui pour un rouge que voyez là c'est la
caméra qui complètement escamotable
manuellement vous allez le bouger là ça
vient la bloquer en termes de
confidentialité je trouve ça vachement
bien alors gaza la caméra est bloqué où
et quand elle est bloquée ça vous fait
aussi un petit point lumineux
la up je fais ça et par contre vous
pouvez aussi venir bloqués ici l'audio
vous appuyez hop ça passe en rouge le
micro était éteint vous rappeler le
micro est allumée en robes étaient comme
ça elle n'entend strictement plus rien
ni aucun google ni rien donc ça c'est un
truc est aussi cool vous retrouver ici
petit bouton de volume tout simplement
et vous allez si un bouton pour
l'allumer et pour l'éteindre
et hop c'est l'étincelle allumée ça
marche c'est pratique
alors moi j'ai fait le choix de ne pas
du tout m 2 de schémas de code chose
comme ça
tout simplement parce que je pars du
principe que lorsque vous allez faire un
ok google eh bien il va faire d'avoir
faire votre schéma et c'est typiquement
pas l'adn de ce produit bon là pour
l'instant je connecte avec le cas parce
que j'ai plus du tout batterie par
contre à l'intérieur vous la voyez en
charge vous avez une batterie de 3000
milliards erreur donc franchement ça
c'est cool vous pouvez venir hop le
débrancher bon bah voilà
là il lui reste encore un petit peu de
batterie il va marcher donc c'est cool
vous le mettez dans un sens vous le
mettez dans l'autre ça marche très bien
ça bouge up mais ça c'est juste les
lettres que vous voyez et en plus il
marcherait
avec google assistant ok google est un
la lumière du studio ça marche
maintenant ce qu'on peut lui reprocher
là dessus c'est que il va tout de suite
moins rapide pour venir faire les choses
par contre il l'effet voulu demander
d'éteindre il est un vrai drame lui mais
il allume il n'est pas hyper hyper
réactive par contre e-marchands de faire
commencer
ok google allume la lumière du studio
donc là on attend le temps qu'ils
prennent voilà et là il rallume
donc vous voyez c'est pas hyper rapide
par contre ça marche donc ça ça fait
vraiment bien le job de ce point de vue
là alors ils fonctionnent bien
évidemment avec et google assistant mais
il fonctionne également avec amazon avec
ça donc ça c'est franchement cool je
vous prends un exemple je suis dans ma
cuisine
j'ai envie par exemple de me faire une
recette donc je sais pas moi je vais me
regarder quoi elle est une recette de
cailles farcies
voilà je ne sais pas pourquoi je pense à
ça c'est très bizarre je ne pense pas
souvent aux cailles farcies
mais là je vais penser à la recette de
la caille farcie donc là je me mets sur
crown je tape caille farcie il souhaite
donc avoir ma recherche de cailles
farcies sur marmitons up par exemple
toutes les cailles farcies sont ici donc
ça c'est cool
ce qui est bien la différence d'un
google comme par exemple dans google au
mini bien là j'ai ma recette
je vais mettre dans ma cuisine je peux à
la fois l'utiliser comme enceinte vocale
comme assistant vocal pour piloter parce
que je veux et en plus de ça j'ai les
visuels j'ai toutes les infos pour mars
est et ça c'est vachement bien
alors vous pouvez faire vous me direz
avec une tablette mais une tablette est
amené à bouger tandis que ça s'est amené
à rester en place en tant qu assistant
personnel et ça pour moi c'est vraiment
bien il faut vraiment que possédant un
lieu qui est vraiment stratégiques
mais pour le coup je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment hyper pertinent et hyper
intéressant pour plus de ça vous rester
en lien avec vos amis parce que vous
avez vous différentes applications vous
télécharger là par exemple j'ai une
messenger et facebook
donc je vais pouvoir me connecter avec
mes amis soutien aux trois qui est
vraiment cool là dessus c'est que
l'audio fonctionne franchement bien je
vous mets un petit morceau par exemple
la haye secousse l'audio à faut donc la
voyais mon bouton de volume
je suis franchement hyper hyper fort
j'ai deux haut parleurs ici de 10 watts
franchement il ya vachement de fond
c'est assez bluffant c'est franchement
hyper cool
ce qui fait qu'au final on a un écran
qui est cool on a une qualité de son eau
qualité pour écouter de la musique sur
ventes en france un connectés ça c'est
franchement aussi hyper cool avec cet
archos et l'os est on n'est pas sûr
qu'un assistant personnel on est sur
bien plus que ça on est sur un objet qui
apporte une autre dimension à
l'assistant personnel au côté
intelligence artificielle avec un google
assistons avec un amazon alexa et c'est
vachement cool et moi je vous dis ce que
j'aime et ce que je trouve vraiment très
très très intéressant là dessus que
c'est tous les usages qu'on peut en
avoir tous les usages liés au multimédia
de le fait qu'avec la webcam vous allez
par exemple pour passer des coups de fil
vidéo avec un whatsapp avec un skype
avec un messenger et ça franchement
c'est hyper hyper cool c'est pour moi
tout le point positif est tout l'intérêt
de cet art cost et l'os est parce que
avoir une enceinte connectés de plus
comme on en a déjà beaucoup
ne serait-ce que sur google ou remis ni
surtout ça ça n'apporte strictement rien
de plus mais le fait d'avoir un écran je
trouve ça bien en plus ce qui était bien
pensée de la part darcos là-dessus ce
que je trouve vraiment très intéressant
c'est d'avoir pensé aussi vie privée
d'avoir pensé à la caméra escamotable de
pouvoir aussi couper le micro sont des
points de détails mais ça permet de
rassurer un peu le consommateur en plus
au dos vous avez un aspect bois qui est
très sympa vous retrouvez le et los
arcos qui est marqué juste là vous avez
aussi le retour avec le grave là ici à
qui sort la halle la basse des petits
patins antidérapants pour le poser de
cette manière là voilà moi je trouve que
c'est c'est vraiment un objet qui est
bien fait c'est un objet intéressant on
objecte lequel on peut pas tout faire
n'achetez pas s'en voulait d'avoir une
tablette enceinte connectez vous allez
franchement être déçu parce que tout ne
va pas être compatible au niveau de la
tablette il faut vraiment le voir comme
un assistant personnel vidéo et ce point
de vue là il est strictement impossible
d'être déçu et je trouve franchement
intéressant elle va forcément se
connecter en wifi vous avez aussi du
bluetooth 4.0
vous n'avez pas de gps va pouvoir
connaître votre position grâce au wifi
grâce au bluetooth mais là dedans par
contre il n'ya pas de gps
maintenant il ya un point de regret que
j'ai là dessus c'est que vous avez une
application qui s'appelle lots connect
qui est censé être un peu le
le centre de la maison le coeur de votre
maison de archos et ça malheureusement
pour moi ça marche pas j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu une application qui
aujourd'hui pas abouti et c'est un peu
un point de regret bon malgré tout c'est
pas du tout ça qui va entacher le
produit parce que je vous le dis vous
avez votre application google com que
j'ai installé juste à côté qui marche
par contre absolument bien google bon
s'est il prouvait s'est arraché pour âge
de tout ce qu'on veut là dessus je peux
tout pile aux des jets pilote ma maison
mais éclairage mon aspirateur mon robot
tout ce que je veux je peux tout faire
avec ça et pour voir qui coûtent moins
de 150 euros 149 euros 90 on peut même
retrouver encore un petit peu moins cher
je trouve que c'est vraiment un produit
qui est super intéressant à voir un côté
tactile un côté visuel avec une super
qualité sonore pour moi c'est un bon
appareil
le seul point pour regret que je
pourrais avoir là dessus c'est qu'il
manque un tout petit peu de jus avec son
méga tech 8167 mériterait d'avoir encore
un petit peu plus peut-être un petit peu
plus de rap il ya de plus de puissance
par contre voulu passer une commande
vocale il le fait il souhaite un tout
petit peu moins rapidement qu'en
nouvelle home mais c'est vraiment du
point de détail parce qu'il fait toutes
les actions vous lui demandez la qualité
cool l'audio est cool l'écran et bien
voilà pour moi c'est un excellent
rapport qualité prix pour avoir une
enceinte connecter plus un écran
c'est franchement cool à vous maintenant
me dire ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire comment vous trouvez pas ce
que vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
par archos c'est l'os est est ce que
vous connaissiez la marque archos est
est ce que au final cet objet pourrait
vous tentez si vous tente
je vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description je vous invite à aller
consulter ma playlist pour découvrir
tous les objets connectés et croyez moi
il y en a un paquet il va y en avoir de
plus en plus et bien évidemment à rester
connectés parce qu'on parlait toujours
plus de teck de produits intéressants et
de tout plein de choses voilà soyez
sages à très bientôt vous embrasse
ciao